Casey Frey's "Get tf out my way type way" is one
of the most artfully produced videos online today
the video tells the story of a man rejecting
criticism and using dance to express his true
self but within such a seemingly simple story
Frey uses innovative film language and symbolism
to create not only an addictive to watch viral
video but also a cinematic masterpiece that
continues to impact the dance videos we see
today first we see the main character chop
a piece of wood then the camera pans up to a
medium shot notice how the character straightens
up to full height as the camera follows him
this movement with the camera adds energy to
the shot and guides our eyesight to his first
shoulder dance move near the top of the frame
this same camera movement later visualizes
his connection with his good alter ego
after the good alter ego pulses his chest
we cut to the main character and both he
and the camera are looking inward
but then they both move outward
showing how the good alter ego's contagious
energy infected him on the inside from here
the camera moves with full force it travels up
his body as his energy moves from his foot up to
his hips then to his arms and his good alter ego
similarly moves with the camera as they connect
Frey uses matching shots to seamlessly transition
between the two characters as they move as one and
they finally join forces in the final frame of
the video to add contrast to this connection the
bad alter ego is filmed in a mostly static frame
and the camera doesn't follow his movements at all
in his last shot he rejects the movement
entirely frank gives his video energy
not just from the camera but from his cuts
like when he cuts to the beat of the music
he also skips frames to make his movement appear
more snappy or when he flips off his bad alter
ego repeats frames to add emphasis to his leg and
hand movements these cuts combined with the camera
movement create a sequence with an electric
hypnotizing energy to really get a feel for
how well he executed this video compare it to
the countless recreation videos while many of
them are great they still reveal just how much
precision Frey put into the editing and camera
work in the original but "Get tf out of my way
type way" is more than just a snappy dance video
it has its own story one with a complete Hero's
Journey the main character has a call to adventure
when starting his dance but he refuses the call
after getting rejected then he meets a mentor who
helps him cross the threshold overcome the abyss
of rejection and transform the story's meaning
can be interpreted in many ways and I'm not the
first to acknowledge it feels like it's about the
worker's revolution it can be read as the story of
a working class man rejecting his manual labor job
and joining a collective in that case the
heartbeat is a symbol of the awakening of
class consciousness in the worker and the bad
alter ego is a symbol for the ruling class who
wants to maintain the status quo there's even
a prominent sign on the glass door that slides
across the frame that says "this property is under
video surveillance" a message which makes the area
feel like an intrusive work zone but i think a
big reason Frey's video has remained so relevant
for so long is because of its universal message of
rejecting the haters and embracing your true self
that general appeal may partly explain
why the video became its own meme format
in this meme the bad alter ego can be any
negative force and the main character is a
rejection of that instruction and phrase video
continues to impact the dance videos we see
online it's one of the most popular examples
of having the camera follow the movement of
the dancer a technique that has become a dance
video staple and the storytelling in his dance
moves sets a standard for character-driven
choreography and for anybody who doesn't
appreciate the cinematic artistry of this video
all i have to say to you is get out my way